- Which character do you relate most to?
- Two characters leap to mind.
One is Maude and the other is
Edith on All in the Family.
She made it big.
- Love Bianca.
I love her.
- The loveliest human
being we all wrote for,
and this was her giant collaboration,
was Edith.
And Maude made me laugh in places
in my body I didn't even know existed.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
I love that.
I would've never guessed that,
and it's two women.
That's amazing the characters you related
to weren't even men.
So you just like to write
better characters for women?
I like you already (laughs).
- I find I like women.
- Yeah, you kinda like them? (laughs)
You invited all of us to your bed.
Obviously, you like some of us (laughs).
- And that was the beginning.
- Yeah, I know!
We didn't even eat dinner.
I like it, I like it, it's a cheap date.